just you you can't believe the numbers
of people that are making their way
across it's just insane you've got to
get the center left people one of them
is a guy like say Joe Rogan this is not
the law the law is that you're supposed
to go through this process where they
vet you and they find out you're a
criminal and they find out if you're a
terrorist and yeah they're not doing
that at all they're just opening the
border and they're essentially buying
votes yeah they're they're doing this
they're they're letting these people
come in and they're assuming these
people are going to vote for the
Democrats mhm and it's wild it's wild
that it's happening right in front of
everybody's eyes and most people aren't
aware of it unless they see these videos
or like Elon was telling me that when
you go there do you really understand
the scope of it he goes it's
extraordinary he just you you can't
believe the numbers of people that are
making their way across it's just insane
it's just and everyone knows about it so
all these people that live in these and
I don't I don't blame them at all man if
you're just a regular person that was
unfortunate to be born in a a Terri
environment and you realize if I can get
to America I can feed my family I can
get a job I can work on a farm I can
whatever it is I can work in a factory
and we could live in a good way instead
of being trapped in this hell hole in
which we were just unfortunately born in
yeah I get
it yeah if I was in Guatemala 100% I'd
have a backpack 100% I'd be on that on
that trk let's go okay Joe Rogan a pot
smoking mushroom eating mostly kind of
you at this point I think you call him
disaffected liberal as far as I know he
didn't even vote last time because he
didn't want to vote for Biden and and
also didn't want to vote for Trump I
don't know that he has said I don't
think he's going to vote again or would
even get go on the record as voting for
Donald Trump uh but Elon Musk who he
referenced said he would vote for
DeSantis would Elon vote for Trump and
it may not matter in the specifics of
whether Joe Rogan or Elon Musk votes for
whoever they vote for but it's they are
the taste makers right so we know that a
certain amount of people can shift
towards a disantis where there's just
that aversion to trump it just is you
may not like it but it just is so the
question is what America First candidate
can actually get some of those people
all of the people who have since October
7th have woken up to what identity
politics have done all of the people who
are seeing violence on our streets again
and Border um Bridges being closed and
everything else an attack on the white
house this weekend by pramas supporters
we're not even covering that today
because it's just happening over and
over and over
again